foreign
Target for that I don't know how this
strange perception is caring about it
sometimes
I have a bit of an impression that
Schultz has lost sight of of the fact
that Germany is actually part of nature
Alliance I mean he's mentally not
westbound it was basically obvious from
March that Ukraine sooner or later would
need a western style battle times
because logistical issues ammunition
issues will become more complicated
longer the war projects and this was a
long war and it was very obvious that
will be a long War now we have wasted
roughly 10 months with endless debates
and we're still there I'd say that the
capability gap between eastern and
western tanks especially if you talk
about elderly Le part 2 a leopard two
versions is not that big but the
logistical difference it makes in terms
of ammunition supplies apply for spare
parts is considerable well the 10th
question is in a war like it is being
fought
every type of of equipment is necessary
and the Russians are fighting with tanks
so the ukrainians need tanks as well
and it was uh General uh kavodi that
said this very rightfully so if you have
a tank on the other side
opposing you you better have a tank so I
think it is in in terms of uh matching
what the enemy has it is important for
the ukrainians and in terms of their
um their ambition to regain their own
territory what was taken from the
Russians a tank is an important weapon
system a balance of all systems is
needed in the end a tank simply comes
down to conceptually a balance between
Firepower mobility and protection and
there are a variety of ways that armies
over the years have sought to provide
that combination that that Holy Trinity
of of capabilities so um there are a lot
of a lot of things that go into this
question with the question
regarding Western tanks I think it's
clearly the case that Western technology
modern Western technology is
outperforming Russian technology
however I would point out that it's not
just tank on tank it's the whole system
it's the supplies it's the logistics
system it's the maintenance system it's
the target finding capability and all of
that comes together so the complex of an
army is much more important than any one
of its individual parts so I hope nope
that was helpful